in the name of jesus
anything it would because it would be of
an antichrist
spirit we break it right now in the name
of jesus every antichrist spirit
we break it right now angels are being
released right now
angels are being dispatched they're
coming here in the name of jesus from
south america
they're coming here they're coming here
they're coming here
[Music]
[Music]
strike and strike and strike and strike
and strike and strike until you have
victory
for every enemy that is aligned against
you let there be
that we would angels are being released
right now angels are being dispatched
here in the name of jesus south america
they're coming here
they're coming here
[Music]
victory victory victory in the quarters
of heaven victory victory victory
victory victory victory victory
today i'm pleased to make a truly
historic announcement in our battle
against the
china virus that will save countless
[Music]
lives
from the blood of recovered patients to
help treat patients battling a current
infection
convalescence
today i'm pleased to make a truly
historic announcement in our battle
against the
china virus that will save countless
lives we provided 48 million
to fund the mayo clinic study that
tested the
efficacy of convalescence
[Music]
convalescent
[Music]
i have with me david pakman he is a
progressive host
an executive producer of the nationally
syndicated radio and tv program
the david pacman show and i wanted to
talk to david patman
he is a beta male 1
david pacman he is
[Music]
can you remind the audience we uh
satirized and remixed
it is trump talking about massive dumps
and by the way
extra points if you can sample trump
saying massive dumps and me talking
about it in a song
please do it
[Music]
big massive dumps
[Music]
that it was massive dumps that led
[Music]
as
[Music]
what is going on here what is going what
is going on here
it's just beyond all right welcome
everybody there's just too much to talk
about to keep this going but that song
by the way reminded me
trump talking about flushing toilets 10
or 15 times producer pat told me
they had a massive plumbing issue at his
place the other day
and instead of 10 or 15 sort of like
discrete flushes with the beginning
middle and end
his toilet was basically on an infinity
flush
i don't know if you guys have ever seen
this where it's almost like stuck
flushing and it's a it's like a
permaflush um
who i mean indoor plumbing is it's crazy
what you can get it to do
um but yeah pat's plumbing going
interactive the other day
and on an infinity flush um
authorities were called in not for this
just for other reasons and a plumber
like the plumber
the authorities weren't there relevant
to the flushing but the plumber was
and they got it all fixed up uh yeah it
was like an
infinity it was a mobius strip flush
for lack of a better term i have so many
exciting things to announce today
i am going to be announcing a contest
where we will be
gifting i will well not really one of
our viewers named stacy
is going to be gifting 10 full price
memberships and we have a contest
and you yes you can win a subscription
either to use yourself or to gift which
is great
um we also are going to be announcing a
position
opening at the david pakman show we very
rarely are hiring
uh but we are going we have a position
that's opening and it will be an
opportunity for some people
to apply i mean i guess we'll say that
um
and then what else i have a new song to
debut
i have a voicemail um
we have many many different things going
on okay and of course
your super chats will be part of the
stream
as well i do want to say thank you right
at the top
um calderash for the nine month
sub on twitch as well as the glaive
and canned caviar as well as trisha
eastman
thanks to the four of you for
subscribing at this very nascent stage
of this
stream i very much appreciate that
um people saying super chats aren't on
screen
you know it's it's actually sad the
super chats are on screen over there
there's just no super chats that's uh
that's the unfortunate uh reality but
everything is working fine don't adjust
your television
i do not have any unban requests today
it's weird because twitch is showing me
that there is one
unban request but then when i click on
it there's nothing there
so in any case i don't have any unban
requests and we will not be uh
gaveling in or out today
um and i guess that's basically it okay
so let's we're standing by for gen
saki at the top of the hour one week
from tomorrow joe biden will be doing
his first press briefing and of course
fox news
for weeks and weeks saying you know it's
been 38 days without a press briefing
it's been 45 days without a press
briefing
it's been 55 days now they announced a
press briefing and yesterday dana perino
on fox says
it's kind of suspicious that they're
announcing it so far in advance it's
really weird
okay so there's that nh barracks
says if they reformed filibuster to
talking filibuster don't they still need
60 votes but now with more delay
i have a full segment on the filibuster
stuff
on today's show okay that'll be
up in about 50 minutes monique mills
says super chat horror
says first ahmad says here you go
starting things off and jake says good
evening david
when do you think the next david pakman
chess tournament will be i don't know
the answer to that
but maybe soon youtube viewer says david
dr
seuss flop now they're on to the crisis
at the border didn't trump's wall
solve that i know yeah we talk about
that on the show today
as well there there's really so much to
going on
to talk about going on i will be
covering the atlanta shooting in fact i
have a clip
this is bizarre to this this police
officer captain jay baker from the
cherokee county sheriff's office
he seemed very unprepared for a press
conference today
here he said that yesterday was a really
bad day for the shooter
it sounds it's just weird take a listen
to this the investigators they
interviewed him this morning and i
they got that impression that yes he
understood
the gravity of it and he was pretty much
fed up and then
kind of end of his rope and uh and
yesterday was a really bad day for him
and
he was he killed multiple people he was
fed up and at the end of his rope and
had a bad day
you know a lot for a lot of people being
fed up and being at the end of the rope
and having a bad day ends with some
cherry garcia ice cream
right it doesn't necessarily end in
killing eight people
and the whole press conference was weird
and i'm gonna have some um
we'll have coverage of this tomorrow and
then there's one other clip here where
so far they are saying they don't
believe that this was racially motivated
but more related to a sexual addiction
this could be in-cell type stuff we just
don't know i have no in
listen you know there's all these people
now uh hot takes on twitter
from people saying oh there's people who
want to call it racially motivated even
though it's not or there's people who
want to say it's not racially motivated
when it is
i want to call things what they are and
we're just going to follow the evidence
but let's let's listen to this
uh we did interview him last night he is
currently in our facility at the
cherokee county adult detention center
uh we were able to interview him did he
say turkey
oh cherokee county cherokee county with
the atlanta police department and fbi
um he made indication uh indicators that
um
he has uh some some issues uh
potentially uh
and by the way killing eight people
would be indicative of that addiction
and may have frequented some of these
places
in the past and but as the chief
indicated is still early on we still
have a lot of
things to process and um so
he should be at an arraignment tomorrow
at some time early
uh morning right to late morning
and we will keep you up to date we have
a press release that captain baker has
put together
available to our our media folks if you
don't have that
i think we have some printed copies that
he'll be uh happy to give to you
uh i'm happy to answer any questions
that you may have shared with
so are you saying you talked to the
suspect he says he has sexual addiction
convictions but i'm sure you have to was
racially motivated what's this racially
motivated
um as the chief indicated uh it's still
early
but uh the indicators right now are uh
uh it may not be uh it may be true
you know people are getting all bent out
of shape now eventually you know
sometimes when it's a lone white guy
it's a lone wolf mental illness and it
has nothing to do with race or whatever
and
it's bs right we'll call it out if
that's the case but
there's no advantage to getting ahead of
ourselves let's
let's just wait to get more information
it could be any of a number of different
things
um let's let's just wait i don't know
what we gain
by saying it was racially motivated
because some of the victims were asian
before we know that to be the case i you
know all the stuff applies
we know that the handling of the white
guy shooters tends to be different than
the non-white shooter
like i know all that stuff but let's
just get the information and then we'll
talk about it
um as it is all right so there is that
that's the latest on the shooter
as we stand by for jen saki
here um a few other
super chats david what are your thoughts
on nationalizing railroads also
hopefully all this talk about high-speed
rail leads to some meaningful funding
for trains and transit
yeah i've i am not um definitive on on
nationalizing railroads or not but
consider that amtrak is heavily
subsidized by the government
so the question would be what would be
what would we be looking to achieve by
changing the paradigm
are you worried about 2224 with
republican anti-democratic
autocratic backslide voter suppression
yes and we have a clip about the voter
suppression
is there equivalent moderna data similar
to pfizer out of israel
no because israel is only using the
pfizer vaccine they made a deal to get
enough pfizer vaccine for everybody
in exchange for data but everything we
know so far is that
just about everything that applies to
the pfizer vaccine applies to the
moderna
correct me if i'm wrong but i'm not
aware of any meaningful differences
between the two in terms of efficacy
side effects
ability to prevent serious covid etc
okay um
let's see where else we want to go i
have a
oh okay update on cases and deaths
we are seeing a continued but slower
decline here i think
it it may it may plateau until we get
significantly more people vaccinated
but as you can see big initial reduction
and then a slower reduction we're down
about 78
79 percent as far as cases go
in terms of deaths the decline is
continuing a little bit more quickly and
that makes sense
this may become eventually something
where cases don't really matter because
if the vaccines turn this into a cold
or a light flu then you'll really be
tracking hospitalizations and deaths
which is sort of what happened with h1n1
where the you know testing for it became
kind of irrelevant because it was like
you it's not operationally different
than the flu
so we're going to follow that uh as far
as
vaccines go we had this massive dump of
vaccine data on saturday
and then we had like okay days we are
approaching two and a half million doses
per day
2.44 million right now okay so that's
all looking
increasingly good we got that out of the
way we got this
out of the way okay good i have
one new song to debut for you guys it is
based off of
um oh wait is this
what is this this may be this may not
even work
huh something see i might have a
corrupted file here
hold on a second i'll tell you one thing
boy trump is more man
than you'll ever be trump is more
american
than you'll ever be so it's based off of
that one this is a new submission
this is a really good one is that new
original sea music
oh my god that's the eggman out of
nowhere i don't even know where that
came from that was so weird i wasn't
even trying to i don't even know where
that's not even in my folder
somehow the eggman is that was weird
okay
this is the new song this is by zeit
it's a play off of fair elise the
uh classical music piece this is called
fur david
featuring m.c haiku hillbilly take a
listen this is a nice one
[Music]
it builds just give it time
this is high quality
[Music]
i'll tell you one thing boy trump is
more
man than you'll ever be trump is more
american than you'll ever be
trump has got more money than you'll
ever have
you are bought and paid for
joe [ __ ] fine
[Music]
joe [ __ ] minded
[Music]
by
i'll tell you one thing boy biden is
more
man than you'll ever be biting is more
american
than you'll ever be biden has got more
money
than you'll ever have trump
is bought and paid for
[Music]
so that's by zeit that's called fur
david featuring
mc haiku hillbilly really strong
really really strong submission guys so
i appreciate that one
from zeit um
okay and a few other people i want to
thank
decoys has subscribed with twitch prime
short brief has subscribed
and uh oh that's it okay those are
subscribers five and six today
super chats edward tyler says hey you
think maybe callers like this guy could
be a bot that's set up for hate calls
no i think it's a real guy i think it's
a real guy
dereten says mcconaughey is starting a
youtube account with somewhat of a
political theme
is it an opportunity for the david
pakman show to get a lead on any texas
governor moves maybe
maybe travis alex says you said on
twitter you never heard of curry ketchup
no i never said that i i've had curry
ketchup
i'm very i couldn't be more familiar
with curry ketchup
what is your political stance on spicy
jalapeno ketchup that i've never heard
of
sam says david have you heard thanks for
all your work have you ever made your
own peanut butter crunchy or smooth i
have never made my own peanut butter
before
nope i am not um i do have one other
voicemail here this is the latest
voicemail from the manic moderate bob in
lakeland florida
yeah there's a bob down here in lakeland
florida you know
down here with my wife rebecca here and
i'll tell you what now
yeah that my pillow guy the guy sells
some overpriced pillows you know
and other price pillars and stuff
and he says he's gonna start a social
media
company he's going to put facebook and
twitter out of business yeah
buddy yeah
i'm telling you and that then that ding
dong down in texas says he got sue
see twitter through twitter for putting
power out of business
that's a good one yeah buddy
yeah i'm in the loop here i got all my
internet got info wars got all the good
stuff
right read all the good stuff and i
ain't being censored by faith i
i sitting around crying about facebook
twitter and youtube
yeah i don't use the damn things you
know right
so there's the manic a moderate uh also
known as yeah buddy and known as bob
from
florida um
i do want to say thanks to jeff munson
jeff munson just did something we can
all only aspire to jeff signed
up at joinpakman.com and his new member
number seven
now i actually i have multiple
concatenated
okay new alert concatenated
uh membership related messages today
number one we by popular demand
have a new unpublished coupon code
on the website the code is immoral 21.
you might say david i see better 21.
no no no immoral 21 is a secret
unpublished code and it's just a
reminder that the coupon codes while
immoral are not illegal
okay immoral 21 is the coupon code now
we also have a new member benefit on
our discord okay here we go now
at davidpakman.com discord there is a
special
designation for website members if you
are a website member and you want to be
badged out on the discord okay
you contact any of the moderators and
they will adjudicate
and confirm your website membership and
you will be designated as such on the
discord
really strong really really strong
additional member benefit
jabygatz on on twitch saying you can
contact jabygatz they're lonely
so give them something to do that's a
good idea um
very very nice okay so that's an
additional member benefit
discord badging and i also want to say
thanks to ryan boyden
for signing up at joinpakman.com number
eight
and then astro lycos has gifted five
on twitch alongside hlve
that's six eight plus six is four carry
the one one plus zero is one
puts us at fourteen okay so there's that
now here we go
announcement i have ten memberships to
give away if you already have a
membership you can still participate
stacy wrote to me okay not my assistant
stacy
different stacy stacy with an ie instead
of a y
stacy wrote to me and said david i want
to do something for the show
i want to donate some memberships okay
stacy has donated 10
full price no immoral discount no
illegal discount 10 full price
we are going to give them away by having
a new
meme contest and i know that we could
make this really vague and just say
send me some image and i'll pick no
we're going to go with something that
has triggered
a lot of discussion okay if you follow
me on instagram
david.pacman you might have seen that
yesterday i posted this picture
okay this is me with the mother lode
a dozen argentinian croissants
in argentina we call them medialunas
look at some of these folks
josh campbell former fbi agent who's on
cnn
he wants me to mail him some of these
triggering
just huge discussion i don't know how
many of you guys know socal flying
monkey
he is an aviation guy who has a
fantastic youtube channel
his mom is argentinian okay
tyler florence of the great food truck
race fame
like this the world is a buzz about
these croissants medialunas
okay the contest will be
with this as the meme format replace
what i'm holding that's the whole thing
okay if you want to keep the boxes but
change what's in the boxes
if you want to get rid of the boxes all
together and put something else in my
hands
if you want to add funny stuff in the
background like i don't i don't want to
in any way influence what can be done
here
this is the format 10 people will get a
free membership
as a result of this now if i just get 10
everybody gets a free membership and
then i'll show you guys the images on an
upcoming stream
if we get a hundred i will probably
whittle it down
to i don't know 30 20 or 30 or something
like that
and then we'll do some kind of voting or
something like that okay
so this is the format i think you can
download pictures from instagram
if you can't like i guess people could
email me for the original picture but my
inbox is gonna explode
i would say don't do that don't do that
i think this is bound to be really good
this is the meme format i have 10
memberships to give away
and um info davidpakman.com is where you
should send
your completed images okay
i think that's everything have i
explained everything
i know that even though i've been super
clear people will still write to me and
say like oh i didn't understand this i
didn't understand that
it's just one image one submission per
person
based on this i have 10 memberships to
give away if i only get 10 everybody
gets a membership
if i get 100 deadline fair
deadline i don't know
by this weekend i'll do this early next
week before we go on screen break
a spring break screen break before i
break my screen i'll do that now before
spring break i will uh
we'll do it alright so try to get it to
me by um sunday
i would say okay so that's that and
we'll go back to standing by here for uh
jen
saki so that's super exciting
uh oh okay the other oh hold on a second
i want to say thanks to edward steele
who just signed up on my website
with the coupon code immoral21 edward is
new member number 15 today thanks edward
really appreciate it
unpublished secret coupon code
immoral 21 you can also get a
member badge on the discord
if you are a member okay i mentioned we
have a new position at the david pakman
show
now we talked about whether we should
announce this to the audience or not
because you know i think people
understand why we might not
want to announce an open position on on
streams
but we have an open position with the
show this is a position that
would ideally eventually be a full-time
position with benefits
but it could certainly start as a
part-time position for the right person
though we envision it becoming
full-time this is a multi-disciplinary
position
you can live anywhere it's a remote
position
okay but we would we work mostly
on eastern u.s time zone all right
the position is a blend of
social media management video editing
ad sales and related tasks and
miscellaneous uh written communication
okay so the requirements are
you either have a college degree or are
in your last semester right now
meaning like you'd be done in may or
june excellent
organizational written communication
skills as well
ability to multi-task ability to work
well in a team
ability to work in a fast-paced
environment
hopefully some of the tech skills but
we can we can teach the tech skills
that's the reality
and um as a part-time position it's
probably like a monday to thursday
thing and then again the idea is that we
get the perfect person and this builds
into being a full-time position
okay so um if you are interested
in applying number one please don't wait
my waste my time if it's not the right
position because we're just gonna we're
just gonna be dumping
uh bad apps uh but you can email info
davidpakman.com i can send you a more
formal uh job description and
uh we rarely have positions available
so it's very very exciting all right
let's mute out here because a lot of a
lot of stuff's going on
um
okay i want to say thank you to benjamin
mcfalls
benjamin just signed up at
joinpackman.com and his new member
number 16 today
i also want to say thanks to what the
spock for the twitch sub
panopt for the twitch sub
that's numbers 17 and 18. very much
appreciate that
guys the coupon code is working
okay benjamin just used it it's immoral
21
lowercase uppercase i don't care it
works uh
edward used it everybody's you the
coupon code couldn't be working more
perfectly it really couldn't
do people want a troy york voicemail
for three consecutive days now
the audience has rejected troy york
voicemails the audience
is sick of troy york voicemails i am
pasting
a new poll in twitch and i am
pasting a new poll in youtube this is a
different straw poll website which
hopefully will work better
let me know and either before or after
the briefing oh it's going to obviously
served as the commissioner of education
in connecticut in this position he faced
the unprecedented challenge of
responding to the covid19 pandemic
and led the safe school reopening
efforts in connecticut
to do so secretary cardona and his
department provided school districts
with the balance of guidance
local autonomy and oversight needed to
ensure
equitable and meaningful educational
opportunities for students
while also prioritizing public health
mitigation
measures since he's our fir it's his
first time here first of many hopefully
uh he has two decades of experience as a
public school educator
he began his uh career as a as an
elementary
school teacher he then served as a
school principal uh so with that i will
turn it over to the secretary
he has a short timeline so he'll be able
to take just a couple questions and
voting is going on okay people can vote
right now the votes are coming in
[Music]
good afternoon oh strong facial hair
nicely trimmed
i'm mickel cardona wow we're at a
critically important time
in our nation's history in education and
i'm honored to serve as the secretary of
education
my goal my my priority right now is to
safely
reopen as many schools as possible as
quickly as possible
right and to do that to do that today
earlier today i notified all 50 states
dc and puerto rico
of the amount of funds they'll be
receiving from the american rescue plan
totaling nearly 122 billion to help them
reopen safely and quickly i'm also
pleased to share that hhs is allocating
an additional 10 billion dollars for
states to do screening and surveillance
testing
of in schools to make sure we can not
only open our schools but keep them open
and then thirdly i'm really really
excited to announce that next week we
will be having our
national reopening
summit for schools where we're going to
hear best practices from across the
country on how to do this safely and how
to do it quickly
right because we know there are great
examples out there we know
students learn best from students
teachers learn best from teachers and
states will learn best from states on
how to safely reopen schools quickly
i'm really excited that dr jill biden
will be offering uh opening remarks and
uh not a medical doctor will also be fox
will tell you
so i'm excited about that you know as a
parent and as an educator
i know the value of in-person learning
and for those of you that are parents
here you know
there's no substitute for in-person
learning so i'm excited to get the
get to work uh making sure we can safely
reopen our schools
as quickly as possible i'll take any
questions you have thank you okay
darlene thank you mr secretary thank you
for being here
um you talked about the money that
you've uh informed state senators let's
go somewhere where we can see the people
asking the questions we always want
that's from teachers and states will
learn best from states
on how to safely reopen schools quickly
i'm really
excited that dr jill biden will be
offering uh opening remarks and uh
dr uh this stream is a little behind but
it's it's typically better
so i'm excited about that you know as a
parent and as an educator
i know the value of in-person learning
and for those of you that are parents
here you know
there's no substitute for in-person
learning so i'm excited to get the
get to work making sure we can safely
reopen our schools
as quickly as possible i'll take any
questions you have thank you
okay darlene thank you mr secretary
thank you for being here
um you talked about the money that
you've uh informed states that they're
getting how will you ensure
that the money is actually spent for the
things that schools need to reopen
that's a great question thank you it's
critically important that we
use the funds to support our students
especially those students who have
had gaps exacerbated as a result of this
pandemic we know
achievement and opportunity gaps have
widened so it's critically important
that
that process is not only communicated
with the with the st
education department but publicly as
well we will be receiving
reports from the states on how they're
going to be using their money and we
also expect those reports to be public
mr secretary thank you for being here
now that teachers are eligible in most
every state what do you say to those
teachers and school officials
who refuse to get vaccinated
well you know the vaccination is one of
those strategies that we know in
addition to the mitigation strategies
allow for schools to safely reopen so
it's critically important that
we vaccinate as many as possible and we
promote the benefits of
the vaccination to make sure we have
safe school communities
so the message really is if if you're
able to get a shot get a shot and you
know that's a strategy to help keep our
schools open
nothing about making a mandatory if
teachers want to come back on vaccinated
that's fine by you
at this point vaccination is available
for educators and i'm proud that the
president prioritize educators
to be vaccinated because we know that
you're not going to get them to say
you're not going to get them to say
mandatory vaccinations are coming guys
the money quickly we know that you said
122 billion dollars will be
given to the states uh from the american
rescue plans right now the cbo
anticipated
that the bulk of the spending of funds
provided through that plan won't be
provided until after 2021 that
there was i think 67 billion dollars
that existed from the past
relief plans that have been passed that
according to the cbo
the bulk of which had not been spent so
why
at first is that accurate and why hasn't
more of that money been spent right now
even before the american rescue plan
money was sent out to get those schools
to safely reopen
we know that uh the bulk of the money is
also being used on human resources and
that's paid out as
people perform the service or are hired
in their contracts
are paid out and services also are paid
when they're
given and we're in march we still have
some of the school year left
we're looking to release funds this
month
and we know that schools are needing
that to not only prepare for reopening
now but also to plan ahead
we know that when our students come back
they're going to need more social
emotional support
we know that our schools have to be
designed to meet the needs of the
students
after they return after a pandemic so
this is a long-term process also that
they
can plan for next year in the following
year as well with this american rescue
plan
announced um 12 billion to help ramp up
testing
in schools how soon before we're
actually going to see some of this
surveillance
yes that's uh 10 billion dollars from
the health and uh
human services uh department so we're
looking to get that soon we know that
that's a
tool to help keep schools open not only
reopen but keep them open uh in the near
future the goal really is this spring we
want our students back in school
uh as quickly as safely as possible and
that's going to assist in that process
and we're more than halfway obviously
through march do you have any kind of
update
on the administration's effort to try
and get every teacher at least one shot
by the end of the month where that
stands
you know i'm really pleased that at the
state level they recognize many states
recognize the importance of uh
vaccinating educators
it's mostly a state question para
educators custodians bus drivers
uh they're critically important parts of
that school community so
we know that that's a priority in
different states and i think it's
as i said earlier it's part of the
strategy to make sure that our schools
are safely reopened
in addition to those mitigation
strategies that we know when working we
can
also use to safely reopen our schools
kristin you're going to have to be the
last one
we'll bring them back thank you and
thank you thank you today the
head of the cdc said that they are
looking to update guidance reducing the
social distancing recommendations from
six feet
to three feet this was one of the the
stickiest sticking points for so many
schools as they tried to reopen are you
at all
frustrated by this potential course
correction
not at all listen we're in the middle of
a pandemic and i i know the success
we've had in connecticut when i was
commissioner of education
was because we work very closely with
our health department and we we
recognize this is the health pandemic
and we're always going to take guidance
from our health experts our sister
agencies that are health experts so
i recognize it's uh it may change
and if it does we're going to be able to
adapt and work with them
we were successful because we work
closely with them and we recognize that
uh
you know that partnership is what's
going to lead to our schools being open
as quickly as possible thank you reduce
it to three feet would it make it much
easier for schools to reopen in your
opinion
if it does uh go to three feet it'll
provide more opportunities
uh potentially for students to enter our
schools which is the goal
that's just math guys something about
the
shootings in atlanta so the president
has spoken out very strongly
would it be easier to open if you only
needed half the space well yeah
americans you know as a education
secretary do you see some role
for the federal government to play in
terms of spreading you know message of
tolerance or
or you know to work against
discrimination my condolences to the
family and the communities
that suffer that violence in education
we have a lot of work to do
we have to reopen our schools and we
also have to make sure that we're
preparing our students for
a tomorrow that we want for our students
so thank you thank you mr secretary
thank you all right thank you all right
secretary of education miguel cardona
thank you thank you so much all right a
couple of other things at the top
um i wanted to make sure that you all
saw the announcement uh this afternoon
from the treasury department that as of
today
they've disbursed approximately 90
million economic impact payments which
of course the checks but most of which
are going through direct deposit
totaling more than 242 billion dollars
following last week's signing of the
rescue plan
this is a key down payment toward the
president's announcement on monday
that 100 million payments would be sent
in 10
days so we'll have we'll continue to
update you as we progress
then the violence against women's women
act as you all know
is being considered in congress today uh
he uh it is one of the pres the original
fasting i should say is one of the
president's proudest accomplishments
the president applauds the house of
representatives which will vote today
to pass the violence against women
reauthorization act of 2021
with bipartisan expected bipartisan
support and with important improvements
to increase safety and service
services for all survivors reauthorizing
vawa
is a priority for the president and he
urges the senate to also come together
in
vawa i like that to ensure swift passage
of awa
so that he can sign it into law soon
with that
darlene go ahead thank you jen
uh first question is there any reaction
from the white house to russia recalling
its ambassador to the u.s they didn't
give a specific
reason for that move but it comes after
a number of russia related developments
uh well we've certainly seen those
reports um
i would say that um you know the uh
our administration is going to take a
different approach in our relationship
to russia then the prior administration
obviously the president spoke
to this during an interview that he
conducted just last night
and we are going to be straightforward
and we are going to be direct in areas
where we have concerns
as you know there is an ongoing review
and the president has well we have
announced key conclusions from an
intelligence community assessment
on the poisoning of alexey novolny we
have there's an ongoing review of other
areas where we have ongoing concerns
at the same time we have areas where we
believe we can work together obviously
the signing of new start is an example
of that
addressing nuclear proliferation is an
example of that
and we we hope that there is opportunity
there but
our relationship will look different we
will be direct
we will speak out on areas where we have
concerns
and will certainly be uh and as the
president said last night
uh certainly the russians will be held
accountable
for the actions that they have taken
we'll have more on that soon
since you mentioned the interview last
night uh the president was asked whether
the vice president is the last person in
the room with him before
decisions and he responded that most of
the time yes
as a practical matter yeah she is
and what then he went on to say for for
for the full context of the interview
that she's traveling around the country
and reference the fact that she
uh yesterday was in denver colorado the
day before was in las vegas nevada that
she has been out there
working her heart out communicating with
the american people so obviously when
she's on the road she's not
the person always last in the room uh by
practicality uh but
otherwise she she certainly is thanks
go ahead uh a question about the
situation on the border it's now been
three weeks since i think in this room
you were first asked about
uh getting us some some press access why
are we still not seeing any images
inside these facilities we remain
committed to doing that and i think
uh these facilities are overseen hhs of
course overseeing uh oversees the
shelters
uh the dhs oversees the border patrol
facilities and
uh we want to work with them to ensure
we can do it respecting the privacy
uh and uh obviously the health protocols
required by covid
but even given covet protocols and
obviously privacy concerns you know
even you all haven't released any images
that you obviously
could redact if you wanted to again we
remain committed to
sharing with all of you uh data on the
number of kids crossing
the border the steps we're taking the
work we're doing to open up facilities
uh our own bar we're setting for
ourselves and improving
the and expediting the timeline and uh
the
uh the treatment of of these children
and we remain committed to transparency
i don't have an update for you on the
timeline for
access but it's certainly something we
support all this you know
we're working kind of they're frustrated
that they can't
show us what's actually happening along
the border they can't do ride-alongs
they can't answer questions
about what's happening inside certainly
seems like there's an element of secrecy
here
why i certainly wouldn't characterize it
that way i know there's border patrol
agents quoted in
a lot of your stories and you speak too
frequently and that's something
we support it's obviously there's a long
tradition of coordinating with
department of homeland security but
uh if we are if our if our policy is is
is
keeping people quiet we are not
successful and it is not our policy
uh to prevent people from talking and
just on one other topic
i wonder if you can explain a little bit
the irs's decision to delay that the tax
filing deadline by a month
of what's the hope of the impact of this
sure i know we've seen some of those
reports uh i don't believe it's been
confirmed or finalized quite yet
um so uh i will let the irs make their
final decisions and then
if if that is what moves forward we're
happy to speak to it go ahead
i hadn't heard about that i just kind of
want to pick up on sharon's questioning
over there
is the white house or dhs instructing
border agents to refuse
right along requests from reporters
because that's what a lot of our folks
on the ground are hearing
again i think we've seen uh watching a
number of the reports you all do
a number of border patrol uh officials
who are quoted in them who are up here
in them and
certainly from the white house we
support that it's coordinated through
the department of homeland security and
i'd point you them for any additional
questions about the logistics of press
access
i mean our reporters used to be able to
get ride-alongs during the trump
administration and you all came in and
promised to be the most
truthful and transparent administration
and you all
you know oversee the department of
homeland security so
if you all wanted to grant access to the
press
couldn't you just tell dhs to do it
again we fully support transparency and
i would encourage you to talk to the
department of homeland security about
any requests you have he needs better
preparation for answering this because
it's like you they could just say give
them access
you know one of the biggest criticisms
of the trump administration's remain in
mexico policy was that it
overwhelmed all these border towns in
mexico and created
pretty dangerous living conditions for
these migrants and so now you have
the exact same thing happening even
though you all have reversed
rescinded that policy these border towns
are overwhelmed
and the president is saying do not come
so
how is the situation on the ground in
mexico
any different well the situation on the
ground is certainly challenging in part
because we inherited a dismantled system
that wasn't prepared for
uh processing asylum requests um that
had
left in place the remaining mexico
program where
people were in a camp that was did not
have the conditions that we felt
popping up well i think what i'm
conveying to you is that we are
less than 60 days about 60 days in uh we
are
working to uh rep to repair what has
been an unprepared and dismantled system
this continues to be the weakest topic
for gensake actually going to
um continue to
make sure we're working through our laws
and the border is not open
but we also as you know have um have
changed our policy to approach it in a
more humane way and keep kids safe
and that requires putting in place more
effective and efficient processing at
the border
it's going to take some time we're
working through it every day we have
new steps and new improvements we're
taking to make the system more efficient
and effective
limit or a cap to the number of
unaccompanied minors that are going to
be allowed into the us
a limit or a cap should so should we
send some kids who are 10 back
at a certain point is that what you're
asking me i'm i'm not setting the policy
here i'm just asking you what the biden
administration's policy is is there a
limit
to the number of of children that will
be allowed in i mean the numbers we're
hearing now 565 on average every day
i'm just curious what the what the end
game is here how many
ultimately would be allowed in well i
think we're where we are
is we're focused on some of the very
specific
numbers so when we came into office
there existed about 13 000 permanent
beds in hhs or
permanent and influx shelter system
facilities
during the last administration thousands
of these beds
approximately half were taken offline
due to covid staffing was also reduced
to put it on par
with the new reduced capacity this was
sufficient for the prairie
prior administration this is how we got
here because they were expelling
children
in addition to families and single
adults we decided as you all know
that we will be more humane about how we
approach this
uh there wasn't operational capacity
built
the prior administration also did not
consider that there were other
mitigation efforts like
masking improve ventilation cohorting
and other measures that would contain
the spread
of covid there's now revised cdc
guidance which means there's greater
capacity in these facilities
where we can expedite children expedite
getting children into them
there are we are taking steps to ensure
that when kids come to the border
we look and see if they have a phone
number in their pocket so we can call
the family member and get them to those
family members as quickly as possible
these are the steps uh that we're taking
at this point in time
our policy continues to be we're not
going to send a 10 year old back across
the border that was the policy of the
last administration that's not our
policy here
go ahead is the if unintentionally in
your commitment to
keep these young uh these children under
17 or 17 under safe
if unintentionally is the us government
incentivizing parents to send their
children across the border alone because
that is their best chance
to enter and stay in the united states
well that certainly you heard the
president say in this interview that he
conducted that he uh is encouraging
people not to come
now is not the time to come this is not
a safe journey for people to take of any
age
and he believes as he talked about last
night that
no parent is looking and just trying to
make a bet
on whether their kid can kind of make it
this is a very
difficult and treacherous journey most
of these kids are fleeing
very challenging circumstances and his
view is that there's a number of steps
we need to take and steps that he hopes
he can work with democrats and
republicans on
so that's his goal how's that message
communicated to that we heard him
obviously in the interview how is that
message being communicated by the u.s
government to those
thousands perhaps tens of thousands who
are already in the midst of this
dangerous journey that they're making
the border right now
and they are not receiving that message
the thousands of children or the
thousands of families
children's families adults all of them
all the in between that our teams from
telemundo and other reporters on the
ground are meeting well
we convey with every official that
speaks ali muyorkas
secretary allen yorkis did an interview
just yesterday uh we've heard you've
heard roberta jacobson speak to this and
a range of officials beyond them
who are speaking directly with countries
working in partnership with them
speaking directly through channels that
are in the region that now is not the
time to come
the border is not open this is a
treacherous journey the vast majority of
people will be
certainly sent back uh on their journey
and that's the message we're sending
i guess it seems maybe it's a mixed
message i don't think the
issue here is that the problem hasn't
been totally solved
i think the issue that it's a mix
between kind of
meaningless statements and sort of
blaming the last administration like i
think if she sat down
for an hour they could hammer out what
the position is going to be and avoid a
lot of the fumbling
come later and others don't come at all
well
i think this is a no doubt a complicated
circumstance and
what we are trying to do is address this
in an effective and humane manner
and uh that requires putting in place
additional policies and measures you
referenced one of them
which is reinstituting the uh
the cam program which would allow kids
to
apply uh from their home country that is
certainly a positive
an option today we are hoping that can
be
happen soon i don't have exact timeline
for you but if we
we would like to put that back in place
it was a program that was already in
place and was ended
in 2017. so that's an example we want to
build
on beyond that so we can have programs
where it ensures that kids are not
taking this
difficult journey that they have other
choices and other options but i was also
and this will take some more time but
we're going to keep seeing these cycles
which we've seen this is not the first
cycle
2014 2018 these numbers have been
increasing since april of 2020 of last
year
unless we work together democrats and
republicans to address the root causes
there have been policies and bills the
president worked with then
with now senator with senator lindsey
graham as an example on a
on a bill to try to give more funding to
address the root causes in these
countries
if we don't take those steps now we're
going to keep being on these cycles
every year year after year one last
question from the interview last night
you talked about the topic of governor
of new york andrew cuomo
i guess my question is why did president
biden feel the need to
weigh in to say that if the claims of
these women were confirmed that the
governor would likely be prosecuted
well the president respects the role of
law enforcement and the justice system
as we
often state from here and see is often
stated he was asked a
specific question about what should
happen in the if the investigation
confirms
the claims of the women um and he
answered that question
so in the past from this podium previous
democratic administrations have said
we're not going to weigh in not going to
put our finger on anything that has to
do
with the justice department or their he
was not saying this is going to happen
obviously the process is going to ha is
going to play out there's an
ongoing investigation that should be
swift it should be thorough
uh and and obviously it will determine
uh
what the outcome is here and he
certainly respects that okay thank you
go ahead this one a couple of questions
so on the atlanta shootings
um uh do you see some need for the white
house and the administration to
create perhaps a point person to address
anti-asian violence even though these
the shooting hasn't necessarily been
linked it is a concern that the
president is raised
is there some move afoot like that well
well first i would say that it's
important to note that um
you know the president as i as i we've
put out a few a few updates today but
just to reiterate
um he was briefed overnight he obviously
talked to the attorney general and the
fbi director
this morning and we're continuing to
monitor the situation as
you touched on local and federal law
enforcement are still determining a
motive they
had their own press conference this
morning that doesn't
change the fact that this news was
horrific and broadly speaking there has
been an increase
as you have noted and we have all seen
in
attacks on in crimes and
hate crimes as well and other
circumstances against
asian americans and that's why he raised
this
in his address when he delivered in his
prime time address
uh on thursday night he did sign an
executive order and actually there are
ongoing processes
including uh from the department of
justice where they're doing uh listening
uh sessions now uh hhs will start those
soon
he's he's he signed that executive order
uh within the early part of his
administration
and he's also asked susan rice and
cedric richmond to do listening sessions
as well
so that we can hear from the community
and determine how that should impact
policies moving forward broadly speaking
as you know there's also an ongoing
review
of domestic violent extremism that is
wide-ranging that is a hundred day
review that will take a look at a range
of issues and that will also
be a longer term strategic comprehensive
look
at um how that impacts our society and
this will certainly be a part of that i
just wanted to follow up on nerd
and north korea talks that are happening
with the chinese
what are you looking for from china on
the on the in terms of his response to
north korea the
u.s military expects north korea to
start testing resume testing of icbms
what would that mean for your review of
those policies
i don't think we're going to get ahead
of their testing
if they are testing if they decide to
test i will say that
part of our strategy as it relates to
the denuclearization of north korea is
of course to lead with diplomacy
and engagement with partners in the
regions even some where we have at times
adversarial relationships
is a key part of that strategy and so
the secretary of state the secretary of
defense
were also just recently in south korea a
meeting with
also with the japanese uh they are key
partners as we discuss security in the
region and certainly
uh the the threats from north korea are
part of that and
obviously that will be part of the
discussion with the chinese but uh our
the strategy is to coordinate and
discuss with partners in the region
so that we can determine what the path
forward looks like and then finally on
mexico
since we're talking about the border but
mexico and canada are also looking
for doses of vaccines there are some
reporting out
saying that you those would be at the
top of the list can you confirm those
reports
can you say you know there's a growing
demand i keep asking this question
you know it's like there's so much
demand out there
and the level of vaccination is so
disparate
in the advanced economies and in
developing countries but also in
neighboring countries like canada and
mexico can you
can you just say what your strategy is
to get vaccines
out to the rest of the world so that
there aren't you know
increases in variance and and and all
the other
negative you know consequences of not
getting the pandemic under control
sure well andrea our our first strategy
is of course to ensure the
american people are vaccinated and 1400
people
a day are still dying in the united
states of america and so we are still
in the midst of fighting a war again
yeah i think there's some element of
like why aren't you sending enough
vaccines elsewhere yet that's like every
country is going to first try to
vaccinate its own people i can't think
of any country that wouldn't
because of operational capacity than
virtually any other country in the world
and we also want to be the president
wants to be
we all want to be contributing members
of the global community and getting the
pandemic under control
any decision we make about requests and
we are we have them from around the
world
as you well know in our tracking will
ensure that we're able to still quickly
vaccinate
the american people as that remains our
top priority we have received requests
from
both mexico and canada and are
considering those requests carefully
uh but i don't have any update for you
on uh whether they will be granted and a
timeline for that
go ahead thank you uh following up on
darlene's question about the russians
who are clearly very upset
what did the president actually mean
when he answered yes or something like
that
to is president putin a killer
was he talking literally or was he
talking metaphorically
i don't have anything more for you to
provide analysis on that
that's my thing extremely upset about it
he also he also repeated a story that he
told in his own book
about a conversation he had with
president putin and uh
as was the k as was evident in the
readout we provided of the call the
president had with president putin
he does not hold back on his concerns
about
what we see as malign and problematic
actions
whether it is engagement in the 2020
intervention in the 2020
election interference a report obviously
released
just yesterday uh their involvement in
the poisoning of alexey navalny
uh ongoing reviews that are related to
bounties on troops and of course the
solar winds hack
so we are he's not going to hold back in
his
uh direct communications nor is he going
to hold back publicly
and we have still found ways to work
together
on areas where we have mutual interest
including the extension of new start by
five years so can you start
yeah that's diplomacy in action there
good go ahead sorry one more
thing yeah if you don't mind yeah um
from moving from russia to uh china
so while secretary's blinking in austin
are out in asia
there's another elephant in the room
which would be the growing talk about
china having designs on taiwan
is the is the u.s publicly committed to
defending taiwan
come what may uh i don't think i have
anything new on our policy as it relates
to taiwan for you today
um obviously there are a range of topics
including taiwan that will be discussed
in these conversations in anchorage that
are happening over the next
two days if i'm getting the time frame
correct and i'm sure the secretary of
state and then our national security
advisor will
come out and engage with the press when
that those meetings conclude
go ahead thanks jen back to that dni
report
there's an assessment in there that
moscow will continue to try to influence
u.s elections
and it said the reason is that the
kremlin has concluded
that it's a manageable risk and so i'm
wondering i know
i anticipate that you're cooking up some
sanctions down the road we've got a
review and whatnot and we've heard some
sharp language from the president
but it seems like moscow has concluded
that they can handle that
and so why wouldn't they continue yeah i
mean we do the same thing in lots of
places too
well first our the president's
relationship
and this administration's relationship
with the russians will be very different
from what we've seen over the last four
years and we've already seen evidence of
that
from his first phone call with president
putin president biden has been clear
that the united states will also respond
to a number of destabilizing
russian actions and as you know and as
we've already talked about
we have requested new or declassified
intelligence community assessments in
four such areas and plan to respond to
each of them
in the coming weeks those are ongoing um
you know i would say that
uh the russians have intervened or
attempted to intervene
in elections for many years i mean long
before 2016
uh and uh we uh you know certainly are
very eyes wide open about that and fully
aware of that
but we are they're going to pay a price
as the president conveyed
last night we are not going to look the
other way as we saw a bit over the last
four years
and we will continue to press them on
their
actions there's some language in that
report it said proxies for president
putin
have have undergone a disinformation or
wonder when a disinformation campaign
in particular alleging or pushing out
disinformation of corrupt
of corruption of president biden and
also the report specifically mentions
his son
so what is his reaction to uh
putin and his proxies going after him
personally that was not our first
awareness of that
um i think we all saw that play out uh
in public
uh so the president felt it was
important to release the unclassified
version of this report which as you know
was the assessment was done under the
last administration
uh it's it is the evidence of the hard
work of the men and women in the civil
service who keep government functioning
but it's important for people in this
country members of congress
other countries to understand uh what
their actions are and
if we want our adversaries our
adversaries like russia
are attempting to divide us and one of
our strategies is to
transparently expose their tactics uh so
that
the world is aware of them so that's why
we release this report
go ahead on the president's interview
he said on taxes that anybody making
more than 400 000 will see a small
to a significant tax increase uh
to clarify did he mean individuals or
households because it wasn't very clear
and secretary allen i think has referred
to households before
families
on schools that is quite different i
mean there's a big difference between
taxes will only go up on individuals
making 400k
versus on households where it could be
200 and 200 or 250 and 150
it's different there's that's that's
actually a significant difference
go ahead oh go ahead go ahead i'm very
drawn to the green
i'm sorry go ahead and the red the red
and the green you know go ahead
the president said in the oval office he
didn't i'm going back to atlanta and
then i want to ask you another question
on the border but uh the president said
in the oval office he didn't want to
make a connection on the motivation
in atlanta but to broaden it out why
does the president
think attacks on asian americans are
increasing in this country
why does he think that's happening well
he he wanted to be very clear because
there's an ongoing fbi investigation
right and he didn't want to attribute
motive there are law enforcement
authorities who do that
um and it's important to note when uh
when the
uh when the investigation is concluded
or not so that was a bar he was attempt
working to respect there
um you know i think there's no question
that
uh some of the damaging rhetoric that we
saw uh
during the prior administration uh
blaming uh
you know calling covid uh you know the
wuhan virus or other things
um uh led to um you know
um perceptions of the asian american
community that are inaccurate
unfair uh have uh raised um
you know threatening has elevated
threats against
asian americans and we're seeing that
around the country that's why even
before
the events of horrific events of last
night he felt it was important to
raise this issue elevate it during his
first prime time address
why he signed the executive order
earlier
in his presidency and he will continue
to look for ways to
elevate and talk about this issue moving
forward president said yesterday he does
not have plans to visit
the border why not because his focus is
on
action and taking actions and moving
forward policies
to ensure why isn't the president
interested in a meaningless photo op
where you don't actually get
policy done putting in place policies
that will move kids more quickly through
the border patrol facilities more
quickly into
safe and secure homes and that's where
his focus is
he doesn't want to get a first hand look
down there himself and talk to officials
there how is he getting
he talks to plenty of officials and he
also has received a briefing
with photos with uh and directly from
his team who went and visited
the border and went to a range of
facilities frequently is he getting
updates on some of the numbers of
uh people who are being taken in and how
frequently is he talking to officials
that are down there
who are getting that firsthand look well
he's getting updates i mean sometimes
it's a part of his pdb
uh he gets updates regularly i mean
several times a week it's an issue that
is front and center for him and
certainly he's asking questions in a
range of meetings
with senior officials about progress
that's made about
systems that he thinks should be unstuck
about looking for more creative ideas to
help ensure
these kids are treated uh they are put
into safe they are treated
put put into safe places and that the
work is expedited at the border
go ahead jen there's a report out that
the president
personally opposes the reopening of
the homestead detention center in
florida does he have a personal view on
it or is he just
deferring to hhs hhs is in charge of
looking at facilities and what um is
which ones are going to be the most
appropriate and effective ones to
reopen and he certainly defers to them
on decisions that are made on that front
because this has been a controversial
and i don't need to tell you this yes
facility in the past
so he doesn't have a particular position
on it it's still on the table that i
could reopen
there hasn't been a decision hhs would
be the ones making a decision i don't
have anything more about the president's
personal point of view about
specific facilities just on uh the
president's remarks on taxes
last night um two things one
when might we expect a major push on
this
and two what does small to significant
mean
it depends on how much money you make
are you a billionaire
then you may pay more in taxes than
someone making
you know family making 425 you know
there's going to be a range in any
tax proposal he talked about this on the
campaign trail
and his he talked about it
during this interview last night in part
because it's on his mind about how to
ensure
people are paying their fair share and
that we are
looking for revenue funds to continue to
build back better
but i don't have a timeline for you and
when you'll hear more it's just uh
something that he
has long had a commitment to and i
expect in the coming months
or sooner than that you'll hear more
about his next stages of his agenda but
uh this is certainly part of what's on
his mind and what he would like to work
with congress on
go ahead yeah in the abc interview
the president said the democracy is
having a hard
time functioning can you clarify was he
just talking there about the
senate and the filibuster is or is it a
broader concern
he was asked in that frame um and asked
in the frame of how to get
work done how to move forward the agenda
for the american people and
the president's an optimist he is a
person who believes that
there is a lot of opportunity for
democrats and republicans
to work together that there is a history
of support for
some of his major priorities whether
it's infrastructure uh or
um uh you know solving cancer
doing doing taking taking steps to to
help cure cancer
uh to increasing america's
competitiveness there's another bill
that's
being considered on that front that
there's a lot of areas where
even immigration there's a long history
of democrats and republicans working
together on that policy
so he's a believer that there is an
opportunity to work together
but what he's seen is democracy having a
hard time functioning and
in part that is why were there no
republicans who supported
a piece of legislation that the almost
80 percent of the american people
it that doesn't seem like it's democracy
functioning there and so he's not
representative anyway
about the filibuster but more broadly
speaking about what he's seeing
and one other thing because we're
required to have an irish question today
sure
in talking to the t-shuck did he make
any commitment
as far as uh once presidential travel
resumes
uh to a trip there i knew in his heart
he would really like to go and i'm going
to go on that trip
um so i'm not aware of any specific
timeline for travel or anything along
those lines that was made i'm happy to
check for you
he has raised several times that next
year st patrick's day will look much
different than this year as i know he
did during the meeting so
you know everybody get get some sleep
and rest before before a year from now
we've got plenty of time
go ahead jeff jeffy said he's briefed
with photos has he asked for or been
shown these photos of inside the
facilities where some of the children
being held for three days
yes that was part of the briefing he
received when his team came back
he approves of what he saw i didn't look
too uncomfortable i know the media
are trying to get in there to get their
own pictures he it looks okay to him
i certainly did not say that uh this is
the
the border patrol facilities are not
facilities made for children
he is committed to expediting
the processing at the border one of the
reasons he wanted a briefing from people
who have been in there
so he can see himself what it looks like
and he has redoubled
he was already committed before this his
efforts to ensure
there's a we limit it uh at two to three
days
um and that we move kids as quickly as
possible into
these shelter facilities where they can
have access to health uh
to medical experts to educational
experts to
legal advice and even beyond that
you know one of the practical steps that
he's really pushed the team on is
how many of these kids when they come
across the border have a phone number in
their pocket
and can we embed hhs and orr in the
system
in the process so that they can call
that number and see if that can be a
vetted family member
to get these kids connected to quickly
so
he wanted all the specific details he
got that briefing which i talked about a
bit in here about a week and a half or
two weeks ago i can't remember the
timeline
and since then we've put in place a
number of steps to expedite the process
to look for additional facilities
and to look for ways to um to improve
the very challenging situation at the
border
let me just go to make sure i get
everyone linda go ahead hi thanks jen
um one for me and then one from i'm the
pool reporter so i have okay another
outlet
so my question actually was for
secretary cardona but i'll ask you
sure is the bible administration
concerned about the number of families
choosing alternatives to public
education
because of the pandemic and does the
administration have a plan to encourage
them to return to public school
it's a great question i wish you'd asked
him that question i'm happy to talk to
him about it i know he had a very
limited amount of time today i was just
excited to get him here
um look you know i know that this past
year has not looked
for school as a mother myself my
daughter did not start kindergarten this
year
and i know a lot of people we know a lot
of people had to make different choices
uh and but i can talk to him more about
what the plans are to encourage people
to get back into the public school
system and obviously that's an important
and vital part of
communities across the country did you
have a second question
the other question from another outlet
so after today's meeting with irish
uh t-shock are there other international
meetings
on the president's agenda in coming
weeks there's
there certainly will be i don't have any
to preview for you today
but engaging he's had a number already
of
remote engagements with his counterparts
around the world
foreign policy is his one of his first
loves and so
i certainly can convey to you that he
will have more of those in the weeks
ahead and
as they're scheduled and finalized we'll
share those details with you go ahead in
the back
yeah the covid 19 vaccines what does the
president say to
americans who have ethical concerns
about taking some of those vaccines
this is the catholic guy they're
conscious
give me a little more information why
would i violate the johnson johnson
one that one has ties to
a connection to abortion derived cell
lines um so some people
uh a word that would violate their
conscience taking that with so the
president would say
what to that he would say i know the
pope has spoken to the safety and
efficacy of yeah the pope said taken
people uh these these vaccines have been
validated by
health and medical experts they're
trying to save people's lives
keep people safe and return our country
to normal on
schools buildings are going on are going
out to try to get them to reopen now
if come fall if schools are still
unopened would the administration find
that unacceptable
we certainly expect schools to be open
in the fall
go ahead airports yep uh tsa reporting
big numbers going to airports is the
administration worried that
the uh kovat 19 response team's message
is just not getting through to people
they're telling people
don't travel don't travel don't travel
and people are plowing through the
airports
well we certainly have to reiterate and
our health and medical team
are doing the same it's not a political
message it's a message from our doctors
that's
just conveying the fact that uh the
guidelines have not changed in terms of
that guy is really boring it's like his
questions aren't even they're not even
interesting um especially you know
there's there are great risks to travel
we've seen
that uh play out they've spoken to this
frequently our health and medical
experts so
we'll just have to keep reiterating that
message we understand it's hard
people want to see their family members
people want to go see their friends
but we are fighting through this
pandemic people are still dying across
the country and
we will we'll keep at reminding people
of that go ahead in the back
press conference next week with the
president any idea how it's going to be
assembled will be in here somewhere else
i don't think it will be in here because
we would it would be very limited
numbers in here
we are working to figure out where we
can do it in the white house to
ensure we have a greater number of
people i'll be covering it
and we will do that in a very
transparent uh manner uh so we're we're
looking we're sight looking at this
point in time and we'll have
more updates for you soon go ahead in
the back first question from
a colleague is president biden going to
call uh as the president of ukraine
zavansky in the near future do you have
any update or
any other potential engagements uh in
the near future
i don't have any previews just said she
did foreign leader calls at this point
typically we
preview those maybe the day he was just
asked about that um but
i'm sure he will have some in the near
future but i don't have any specific
ones to preview for you today and on the
vaccine
uh the president said yesterday that the
u.s is in talks with several countries
about sharing
uh vaccine in the past you criticized
russia
and china for so-called vaccine
diplomacy
and you suggested that it should be done
through international
projects or institutions
so do you exclude
sharing vaccine on a bilateral basis
i think our criticism was in response to
questions about whether we were
concerned
about how vaccines were being used in
some ways
by russia and china in ways that they've
used
aid and and international assistance
where there are no strings attached and
uh sometimes it allows countries to hold
themselves to lower standards on
human rights on freedom of press freedom
of speech
and we've seen that play out as we know
in recent years
so that certainly would be something
that is of concern to us
we have not yet uh provided vaccine
doses to
uh any country we are we of course have
a range of requests and a number of
requests and
uh we will consider those carefully but
since we have not done that yet
i don't really have anything more to
update you on back on the border yeah
um you talked about the team that went
to the border yes briefed the president
they've shown him photographs yeah i
think there was a request at some point
to have
members of that team come back come to
the briefing room and do a briefing
so where does that stand and since there
are photos
from that team why not release those
since with the previous lines of
questioning you have said
go to the border patrol or go to dhs for
the access questions
i'm happy to invite them to the briefing
room and talk to them about the photos
and will that team return to the border
or some other configuration of
staff members will they be making
periodic trips down there to assess
conditions or
was this one and done i expect we'll
have additional
trips to the border but i don't have one
to preview for you today
thank you everyone
i was saying that if you're a
billionaire you're gonna pay
more in taxes than somebody making 425
over 400
over 400 i was just as an example oh
okay yeah okay sorry i wasn't trying to
change the threshold yeah we were just
like oh no
no no i should have used something more
you know 572.
something thank you thank you all right
there is white house press secretary jen
saki
and we will indeed have um
the joe biden press briefing on thursday
before we head out on spring break
let me see here i'm going to get to
super chats because i know people get
very angry
if i don't and i'm making an effort to i
do want to say thanks to oceanova
who has just hit 20 months subscribed on
twitch i think we only have a handful of
people at the 20-month mark it's really
an incredible incredible number and i
appreciate it
so so much i also want to again uh
people asking
uh inconsolable is still the top top
gifter on twitch with 542 subs gifted
david chadman with 323 subs gifted and
spudnik with 258
big thank you to debra green for signing
up on my website
i want to say thank you to maria lewis
who used the new secret coupon code
immoral21 sparkle armadi
is a new member rachel rick
benjamin mcfalls and just really really
great people
let's look at some super chats having
republicans shout falsely for the past
year that democrats want open borders
doesn't help the migrant situation
republicans created this crisis as a
self-fulfilling prophecy
of course how dare you drop a video
while we watch
live oh well yeah those are two
different uh
it's we the the live people don't talk
to the clip people
let's put it that way we're keeping
separation russia china
india belgium other countries are
sharing vaccine that's how we've gotten
vaccines
in many countries all right very good
hi david i missed the first half of your
statement where is the best way to reach
out about the open position
info davidpakman.com
dr seuss is also not a medical doctor
not even a phd
that is true one day david will have a
complete bill o'reilly style meltdown
over people saying the coupon code
doesn't work the coupon code works
the coupon code works like the stream
you're here
give this guy i guess that's me a thumbs
up and get more folks in here
tesla wants to know how would i gift
memberships if you want to give
if you want to give one person a
membership you just go to our website
and you put their name and email
in the sign up okay make sure to be
logged out if you want to give a gift a
bunch of memberships like stacy is
gifting 10 memberships
you email info davidpakman.com and as a
reminder i have 10 memberships to give
away
the concept is do a photoshop
of this is this is my latest uh
instagram post that david.pakman
do something with this okay i already
got
three during the stream we got three
during the stream
any modification you want to make change
what i'm holding
put something different in the boxes
change the paintings
put something in the background it's
wide wide open okay but this is get them
to me by sunday
i have 10 free subscriptions on my
website
for the top 10 maybe we'll have people
vote maybe we won't we're going to see
okay so that's the latest as far as that
goes and um
david by delegating things to a new hire
what will you and other staff do with
free
time no the the new hire is going to be
mostly doing new things
we're building building building
building all right everybody happy st
patrick's day to everyone use that
immoral coupon code immoral 21
and we'll be back with everybody
tomorrow we've got a great video coming
in about 20 in about five minutes on
youtube five minutes on youtube alright
we'll see you there